Switching to Allstate
is worth it.
>> WE MADE THE POINT THAT MUCH
OF THE NEWS AMERICANS ARE TOLD
IS FACTUAL TURNS OUT TO BE
PROPAGANDA.
HUMAN BEINGS LIE.
POWERFUL PEOPLE TEND TO RELY
QUITE A BIT IN ORDER TO PROTECT
THEIR PREROGATIVES.
JOURNALISTS OF THE ABILITY TO
RESEARCH SHAPE PERCEPTION ARE
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE TO
DISHONESTY.
THERE IS NOTHING CONTROVERSIAL
ABOUT THAT.
IT'S TRUE.
YET MAYBE NOT SURPRISINGLY, A
LOT OF REPORTERS FOUND IT DEEPLY
OFFENSIVE.
REPORTER AT "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
CALLED IT "REPUGNANT."
HE SAID IT'S "LITERALLY DAMAGING
TO OUR DEMOCRACY THAT ANYONE
WOULD DOUBT THE ACCURACY OF HIS
NEWSPAPER."
QUESTION "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
THAT AMERICA FALLS APART.
PRETTY FUNNY.
IN OTHER NEWS, CARRIER HAS
ANNOUNCED IT'S IMMORAL TO NOT
USE AIR CONDITIONING.
AS IS SO OFTEN THE CASE, THE
OPPOSITE IS TRUE.
SKEPTICISM IS NOT UNPATRIOTIC.
IT'S YOUR DUTY.
PRINCIPLED QUESTIONS DON'T
DESTROY DEMOCRACY.
THEY SUSTAIN IT.
PEOPLE IN CHARGE DON'T LIKE TO
BE SECOND-GUESSED AND WHY WOULD
THEY?
A SKEPTICAL POPULATION MAKES
THEIR LIVES MORE COMPLETED.
THEY WOULD LIKE YOU TO SWALLOW
YOUR MEDICINE WITHOUT COMPLAINT.
SHUT UP AND OBEY.
DON'T ASK QUESTIONS.
EXCEPT WHAT YOU ARE TOLD AND GET
BACK TO WORK.
THAT'S A LOT TO ASK.
ESPECIALLY COMING FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WHERE
THERE'S A LOT OF INTERESTING
DETAIL IN THAT NEWSPAPER
DAY-TO-DAY AND GOOD FOR THEM FOR
PRINTING IT.
BUT THERE'S ALSO AN AWFUL LOT OF
LYING, ESPECIALLY ABOUT THE BIG
THINGS.
REMEMBER WHEN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" SPENT AN
ENTIRE YEAR ASSURING US THAT
SADDAM HUSSEIN HAD WEAPONS OF
MASS DESTRUCTION?
WE WENT TO WAR OVER IT.
MANY THOUSANDS DIED, AND IT WAS
A LIE.
HOW ABOUT WHEN THE TIMES TOLD US
BARACK OBAMA'S TOPPLING OF
MUAMMAR QADDAFI WOULD TURN LIBYA
INTO "A PRODUCTIVE PARTNER WITH
THE WEST."
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO KNOW
WHAT THE FAMILIES NOW BEING SOLD
IN LIBYA IS OPEN SLAVE MARKET
THINK OF THAT PREDICTION.
WHO CAN FORGET THIS TIMES
HEADLINE FROM THE SPRING OF 1975
WHEN THE KHMER ROUGE TOOK OVER
CAMBODIA.
"FOR MOST, A BETTER LIFE."
A THIRD OF THE POPULATION WENT
ON TO DIE IN GENOCIDE IN
CAMBODIA.
THE TIMES HAS YET TO ISSUE A
CORRECTION.
NOWADAYS, THE TIMES IS HYPING
THE RUSSIAN HOAX TELLING US
MOSCOW IS THE GREATEST THREAT TO
THIS COUNTRY WHEN IT'S CLEARLY
NOT.
THE PAPER IS TRYING TO PROVOKE
YET ANOTHER POINTLESS WAR IN
SYRIA BY PUSHING THE CLAIM THAT
BASHAR AL-ASSAD GASSED HIS OWN
PEOPLE.
AT TIMES REPORTERS PRETENSION
OVER SHORT AND THAT HAVE
HAPPENED.
THEY DON'T KNOW IT FOR CERTAIN.
THEY ARE LYING.
WE COULD GO ON.
WE ARE NOT MAKING A PARTISAN
POINT.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS HARDLY
THE ONLY POWERFUL INSTITUTION
THAT DISTORTS THE TRUTH.
SOMEDAY SOON MAY BE THIS WEEK,
THE REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP IN THE
HOUSE MAY ANNOUNCE AN AMNESTY
FOR MORE THAN A MILLION PEOPLE
IN THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
THEY WILL TELL YOU LETTING
FOREIGNERS IGNORE OUR LAWS IS
GOOD FOR AMERICA.
DON'T BELIEVE THEM.
THEY ARE LYING.
OUR COUNTRY HAS CHANGED A LOT ON
THE DIVIDE IS NO LONGER BETWEEN
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS WERE
GIVEN BETWEEN LEFT AND RIGHT.
IT'S REALLY BETWEEN THE
INCOMPETENTS IN CHARGE AND
EVERYONE ELSE.
A SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE HAS
BECOME RICH AND POWERFUL,
MISMANAGING THIS COUNTRY.
I HAVE WRITTEN A BOOK ABOUT
THEM.
IT IS CALLED "SHIP OF FOOLS,"
OUT IN OCTOBER.
ORDER IT NOW IF YOU WANT.
IF YOU DON'T REFLEXIVELY OWE
ANYBODY OR LEGIONS OUTSIDE YOUR
IMMEDIATE FAMILY THAT INCLUDES
THE NEWS MEDIA.